menteur invétéré capable des pires excès
de violence pour parvenir à ses fins ou
petit caïd attirés par les belles
voitures et des objets bling bling de
portraits bien différent de jacky
martens présentés par l'accusation et la
défense c'est un homme qui n'a pas du
tout le profil effectivement de d'un
criminel de ce type nous avons entendu
les témoins certains sites et d'ailleurs
monde et du parquet général ont pu
confirmer et naturellement qu'il n'avait
pas de défiance qu'il n'avait jamais été
concerné effectivement par des
agressions sexuelles de qualité que ce
soit et on s'aperçoit au fur et à mesure
que le procès effectivement se déroule
et que cet homme n'a pas le profil de
qu'on veut à tout prix le tribut à la
barre quatre de ses ex compagnes se
succèdent
elle parle d'un homme protecteur et
attachant seule une altercation entre
l'une d'elle elle accusé
ce soir-là jaloux de la voir danser avec
un autre jacky martens et sectes
s'accompagne de la piste en l'empoignant
par les cheveux et le bras sur ses actes
de délinquance elles sont toutes formes
elle la veut ne fait pas partie de sa
culture
à chaque fois il m'a toujours certifié
trio s'en déclare l'une d'elles
certaines compagnies ont évoqué un
menteur pathologique d'autres inventeurs
chronique
toutes ont expliqué que monsieur jacky
martens est quelqu'un qui est capable de
s'auto persuader de ses propres
mensonges et qu' il peut parfois même
pris la main dans le sac avoir une
version très très étonnante et être
incapable de constater et de réaliser
les choses telles qu'elles s'affichent
entre de manière extrêmement claire à la
barre également aujourd'hui la mère de
jacky martens en larmes
d'une voix douce elle déclare tout le
monde sait que mon fils est un
délinquant mais il n'a pas pu commettre
ce meurtre
mais lorsque l'avocate générale lui
rappelle qu'il a été condamné en 1999 à
6 ans de prison pour vol avec violence
sur un homme de 64 ans d'une voix moins
douces avec la même certitude elle lui
répond non madame
il n'a pas pu faire ça